presidential debate last night you watch
yeah did you watch what are your
thoughts what are your opinions well
supercalifragilistic expialidocious
braggadocious he said the word
braggadocious at one point you did yeah
[Music]
so I'm taking it you are not a trump
supporter then no but he is the one
thing is he is golden because he gives
you so much to talk about yeah I'm so
much to laugh about so you can't knock
him all the time because he is a source
of enjoyment because he makes you love
yes yes unfortunately that is not the
job that he's he's very entertaining yes
the thing is even if he gets in he won't
last have his ass out of there before
free for Christmas I don't think you
understand how our system works wander I
think you'll just get bored I don't
think he I mean there's a school of
thought that he doesn't really want the
job that he got into this to sell steaks
and then it got much further than he
thought I think he thought to himself
I'm with you on this he thought to
himself hey you know it can only help my
brand they'll they'll be you know
renting my name to put on every bloody
building around the world and so we can
only help me and then because he makes
everyone laugh he's he yes yeah I don't
think he wants to work right I don't
think he wants to do it but he's like
stuck now I'm curious Melania where do
you think she is in all this do you
think she's happy does she want to be
first lady no come on
this poor girl you know lovely girl gets
stuck with him it's all right you know
it's all right
and suddenly they want to know who her
parents are where she was born did she
get a college degree this that the other
this girl didn't sign up for that sheet
she just wants to walk around with her
amaze bag and you know as much makeup on
the face as she can get on tipeee
in us and she's everybody wants to know
yeah about her education right right
right so that was not part of the deal
there when she was just up for that
other part with the tits in the app you
fall asleep you don't see you in the
morning did you see her last night did
you see the dress yeah oh oh yeah it was
the breasts were standing shoulder let's
dress yeah incredible that's ready yeah
you're very limber Sharon now we know
why Ozzie never ran
you